y
[Música]
francia vive el peor momento de la ola
de calor que está sufriendo el
continente europeo la capital parís
alcanzó este martes los 41 grados
celsius reino unido- superó también los
40 grados rompiendo el récord de
temperatura máxima del país
queda tan solo tres candidatos para
sustituir a boris johnson al frente del
gobierno y del partido conservador
británico el ex ministro de finanzas
risk es una parte con ventaja pero la
ministra de exteriores listas podría
acercarse al sumar los votos del ala más
derechista del partido
en sri lanka tú las ala perú ma se
postula como uno de los contendientes
más fuertes en la votación legislativa
por la presidencia luego de la crisis
política que desató masivas protestas
deberá enfrentarse a rne el wii que me
singer presidente interino y aliado de
los depuestos hermanos raya pacsa
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en reino unido
que registró hoy su día más caluroso
alcanzando una temperatura récord de
40,2 grados centígrados el calor
abrasador ha provocado ya grandes
trastornos en el transporte y también
está presionando al servicio de salud
las personas han buscado refrescarse en
las playas del país y el panorama para
los próximos días parece que no mejorará
el servicio de ambulancias de londres
afirma que el lunes recibió 6 mil 600
llamadas relacionadas con esta ola de
calor
es el principal tema en los titulares de
este martes en reinounido luego de vivir
la noche más calurosa que se ha
registrado hasta el momento los
británicos se despertaron preparándose
para un calor de 40 grados celsius
temperaturas nunca antes vistas en el
país la ola de calor ha hecho que los
habitantes de las ciudades huyan en masa
a las zonas costeras las playas de todo
el país están inundadas con miles de
personas desesperadas por mantenerse
frescas este es un buen llamado para que
todos nosotros entendamos que es
necesario hacer frente a los costos del
cambio climático hemos estado alertando
en la comunidad científica así que
espero que no solo nos adaptemos sino
que preparemos nuestras ciudades para
hacerle frente a estas olas de calor que
cada vez son más frecuentes
la gente no es la única que está
luchando contra el calor el sistema de
transporte también está haciéndole
frente a la situación los días de
temperaturas abrasadoras han provocado
importantes interrupciones en los trenes
los operadores de trenes han pedido a
las personas que viajen sólo si es
absolutamente necesario
el tren elevado si no está tan mal el
aire acondicionado no funciona y
funciona en invierno no puedo creerlo
pero si ayer fue lento llegar a casa así
que hoy saldré un poco antes si el
ministro de transportes británico grant
shapps advirtió que podrían pasar años
antes de que las infraestructuras del
país puedan actualizarse completamente
para hacer frente a las altas
temperaturas un proceso que ahora tendrá
que acelerarse
al tiempo francia vive también el peor
pico de esta segunda ola de calor en
europa la capital parís alcanzó este
martes los 41 grados celsius esto supone
un alza de 15 grados por encima de la
temperatura media de julio todo el país
se encuentra en alerta naranja ahora
mismo con estas temperaturas parisinos y
visitantes aprovecharon para aliviar el
calor en las fuentes y en las playas
fluviales del río sena
y en reino unido el partido conservador
ha llevado a cabo una nueva votación en
el proceso para elegir el reemplazo de
boris johnson como primer ministro ya
sólo quedan tres candidatos y el ex
ministro de finanzas risas una que va
con ventaja en las votaciones la
secretaria de estado de política
comercial penny more dance y la ministra
de exteriores listas son las otras dos
aspirantes anteriormente nuestra
corresponsal en reinounido luisa pulido
no se ampliaba
si se va perfilando como el gran
favorito dentro de los diputados del
partido conservador que son quienes
eligen a los dos finalistas
otras de las elegidas se perfila como la
favorita dentro de las bases según las
encuestas que se han revelado
recientemente la cuarta eliminada de
este proceso hace apenas unas horas es
que me iba a tener quien fuera ministra
júnior o viceministra de mujeres y
equidad que dan en este momento tres
candidatos en la carrera además de richi
zoom aquí penny motion también la
ministra de exteriores listas y como lo
mencionas richie zona que es el gran
favorito este miércoles quedarán los dos
finalistas y entonces terminará el
proceso de los diputados tories y luego
estos dos elegidos arona harán una gira
por todo el país para convencer a las
bases y el nuevo primer ministro se
conocerá el 5 de septiembre
como nos indicaba nuestra compañera el
ex ministro de economía británico está
considerado como uno de los favoritos
para tomar las riendas del partido y
sustituir a boris johnson como primer
ministro esto sin embargo no significa
que tenga la victoria asegurada listas
ex ministra de exteriores y
representante del ala más derechista de
los tories podría ser una rival fuerte
al acaparar los votos de que me va de
nov representante también del ala más
dura del partido pero conozcamos más
sobre la figura de sunat
uno de los primeros en lanzar la
rebelión contra a boris johnson el
ministro de finanzas- risis unac se
apresuró a anunciar su candidatura a la
cabeza del partido conservador y por
tanto a primer ministro
me presento para ser el próximo líder
del partido conservador y su primer
ministro a sus 42 años risas una que es
parte de una joven generación de
conservadores tras estudiar en la
universidad de oxford comenzó su carrera
como analista en goldman sachs fue
elegido diputado por primera vez en 2015
y apoyó el break city en los debates
previos al referendo de 2016 se
incorpora al gobierno de theresa may en
2018 como secretario de estado para el
gobierno local sunat ascendió
rápidamente en el escalafón oryzon sólo
nombre del secretario jefe del tesoro en
2019 y luego ministro de finanzas en
2020 cuando la crisis del cob y 19
golpeó al país anunció un importante
plan de recuperación
hoy anunció un estímulo fiscal de 30 mil
millones de libras para apoyar a los
británicos los empleos y las empresas
británicas en este momento
conocido por su conservadurismo fiscal
es una que ha hecho de la recuperación
el centro de su campaña me encantaría
estar aquí y decir mira voy a recortar
este impuesto a que el impuesto y otro
impuesto y todo estará bien pero saben
que no lo estará esta economía de algo
por nada no es conservadora es
socialismo según una encuesta realizada
entre cuatrocientos noventa y tres
miembros del partido conservador crisis
una que es del candidato más popular
entre sus compañeros por delante de la
ministra de asuntos exteriores list
trust hijo de un migrante indio si haz
elegido sería el primer ministro no
blanco del país tras largos años de
espera albania y macedonia del norte
finalmente iniciaron los diálogos con la
unión europea para entrar a formar parte
del grupo comunitario las negociaciones
estaban previstas para 2018 pero varios
países como francia alemania y países
bajos bulgaria retrasaron el proceso con
la petición de nuevas exigencias a los
aspirantes entre ellas el cambio de
nombre de macedonia a macedonia del
norte o el reconocimiento constitucional
de la minoría búlgara en el país
fondeur legend felicito al presidente de
albania por su logro
[Música]
en sri lanka uno de los fuertes
opositores del gobierno sayid premadasa
decidió dar un paso al costado en la
competencia por la presidencia lo hizo
para respaldar a dudas a la perú ma
quien será el contrincante del actual
presidente en funciones ranil be creeme
singer precisamente hoy hubo nuevas
protestas contra este último señalado de
ser aliado de los depuestos hermanos
rajapaksa un candidato menos en la
carrera para suceder a gotabaya
rajapaksa el principal opositor sayid
premadasa declinó sus aspiraciones para
respaldar adular a laja peruna un ex
periodista cinco veces legislador y
visto como un político de bajo perfil
la gente que está en el parlamento en
esta pequeña isla rodeada por el lago
villa juana no puede entender la voz de
la gente que está afuera
y lo que piden es que se cambie esta
cultura política que se introduzca una
nueva cultura que se reúna al pueblo
mi capacitiva
hicimos este sacrificio por la gente
cómodo y las victorias políticas
personales deben convertirse en
victorias para el país
aporta vaselina
lo que queremos es que gane el país
queremos que gane el pueblo
entre los candidatos está el presidente
en funciones running y créeme singer
quien causa malestar entre la población
por tener el respaldo de los raya para
c's a la gente volvió a las calles esta
vez para exigir que él no sea elegido
como sucesor
si tenemos un país en el que no hay
colas en el que tenemos comida para
comer en el que se cuida la educación de
los niños y en el que la gente vive en
libertad eso es suficiente no puede
haber más mentiras ni corrupción si eso
ocurre volveremos a salir a la calle
todos nosotros saldremos a la calle
el parlamento con 225 escaños votará
este miércoles para elegir al nuevo
presidente que deberá intentar conjurar
la crisis en la que está sumida esta
isla de asia del sur las manifestaciones
entre la ncaa llevan meses atizadas por
los altos precios del combustible y la
comida además el país debe al fondo
monetariointernacional unos 51 mil
millones de dólares por lo que no puede
acceder a préstamos de emergencia que lo
ayudarían a salir a flote
nos vamos hasta perú el país que tiene
la gasolina más cara de toda
latinoamérica la agencia financiera
bloomberg señala que el precio del galón
de gasolina es de 63 dólares
estadounidenses en promedio la razón
impuestos elevados una costosa cadena de
comercialización y los altos costos de
producción de las refinerías entretanto
los peruanos buscan otras alternativas
para poder abastecer sus autos con
combustible nuestro corresponsal en lima
francisco zacarías nos amplía la
información en este reportaje
luis alcántara fabrica muebles de acero
y en sus ratos libres es taxista sin
embargo debido al elevado precio de la
gasolina ha decidido modificar su carro
a gas natural vehicular para poder
seguir generando ingresos como conductor
para todos los 30 críticas por eso ya
con cambiando legal la mayoría se borra
para algunos que también viven del taxi
no my peor debe ser yo que tengo trabajo
haití va a ir también pataleando ya que
poco a poco ya la que todo esto pasión
así como louis muchos peruanos se están
recurriendo a la conversión de sus
vehículos de gasolina a gas natural
aprovechando un financiamiento estatal
sin intereses eso permitirá a los
usuarios un ahorro mensual de cerca del
70%
según la asociación de estaciones de
servicio en el último año los precios de
las gasolinas de 91 95 octanos han
subido a 35 y 47 por ciento
respectivamente las causas del
sobreprecio impuestos elevados una
onerosa cadena de comercialización y los
altos costos de producción de las
refinerías subieron combustible sube
todo porque todo se transporta
con algo que gaste combustible y acá
pagamos los sueldos millonarios de los
funcionarios de petroperú y sus coimas
en todo lo que compra eso es lo que
estamos pagando por eso pagamos el
combustible más caro de sudamérica según
los analistas el elevado precio de la
gasolina repercutirá negativamente a
largo plazo en la economía peruana ese
aumento muy fuerte del precio de los
combustibles
obviamente está haciendo que la
inflación suba fuertemente y golpe más a
los que menos tienen por qué porque los
sectores de bajos ingresos más del 50
por ciento de su gasto diario lo
destinan a alimentos y combustibles
el estado ha destinado más de 630
millones de dólares en exoneraciones
tributarias y subsidios en un intento de
combatir el alza de los combustibles no
obstante diversos agentes económicos
prevén que durante julio los precios
seguirán altos y que la inflación
alcanzará el 9%
seguimos en américa latina' y nos vamos
ahora hasta panamá la ruptura del
acuerdo entre el gobierno y los gremios
para congelar los precios del
combustible generó nuevas protestas el
lunes en el país conozcamos de primera
mano el contexto de las protestas que
han sacudido a este país centroamericano
en el siguiente informe
panamá se sumó a la ola de protestas
latinoamericanas de los últimos años un
descontento que coincide con la invasión
de rusia a ucrania guerra que ha
trastocado las economías de todo el
mundo pero que ha desnudado problemas
estructurales
ya son más de dos semanas de las
protestas más grandes desde la caída en
1989 del dictador manuel antonio noriega
se empiezan a ver imágenes de
desabastecimiento por los cortes de vía
en unas marchas iniciadas por maestros
ya las que se fueron sumando otros
sectores desde la construcción hasta el
movimiento indígena la inflación
interanual se sitúa en un 42 % los
principales reclamos son consecuencia
del golpe al bolsillo del ciudadano el
precio del combustible aumentó en un 47
por ciento en los últimos seis meses y
el galón llegó a superar los cinco
dólares antes de ser reducido por el
gobierno el índice de precios al
consumidor aumentó en un 3,3 por ciento
respecto a 2021 por lo que también se
han congelado el aumento del coste de 10
alimentos de la canasta básica pero más
allá del momento panamá tiene 4 millones
de habitantes el 20 por ciento de la
población vive en condiciones de pobreza
y la mitad trabaja en empleos informales
eso en un país que en 2021 creció un 17
8% y que posee un canal que le reporta 2
mil millones de dólares al año sin
embargo es uno de los países más
desiguales en el mundo con frecuentes
casos de corrupción como el popular
macro caso de la constructora brasileña
odebrecht que salpica a los dos últimos
ex presidentes
y hasta aquí llega este repaso a las
principales noticias internacionales
sigan conectados a france 24 y recuerden
que pueden ampliar toda la información
en nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]